okay bgp is the border gateway protocol
and it's in it's a routing protocol that
evolved in the internet and it's you can
think of it as kind of the the top of
the food chain in terms of routing in
the internet it's the it's the protocol
that's used to connect the service
providers let's say primarily in the
internet so how does AT&T exchange reach
ability information with bt with France
Telecom with you know and they have to
exchange this kind of reach ability
information so that we can glue that
these autonomous networks together
because there is no one there is no
centralized control in the internet you
know so BT controls its equipment and
it's part of the internet but AT&T
controls its part of its own part of the
internet and they have to interoperate
somehow they have to be able to exchange
information about the IP addresses
associated with their customers and etc
so the border gateway protocol BGP is
this protocol that has evolved to handle
that job right to exchange information
between autonomous networks okay so
without any centralized control there
are many interesting engineering
problems they're interesting research
problems in terms of scalability and
robustness etc and but I'm going to talk
about it in really sort of elementary
terms and I want to I want to be I want
to talk about a simple graph problem as
a reach ability problem in graphs in
simple combinatorial graphs with where
we have nodes and arcs and we want to
get from one place to another you send a
packet to your service provider it has
to look in a table and figure out where
to send that next and that packet may
end up on the other side of the globe in
a completely different network and and
so it's that level you know it's it's
how to get from here to there so it's
the Foundation's on the internet it's
the basic global foundation of the
internet different protocols are used
within these autonomous networks and I
think more talked about that in a
previous computer file and you know for
example you might use some kind of
shortest path based thing within a
network but between networks what's
interesting about this is that you know
we want this inter domains or you know
regional autonomous networks we want
this routing to interoperate to work
even when the service providers don't
have common agreement about what is the
best rap for example you know your best
route might not look like my best route
because we have different contracts with
with different companies in the internet
and so we have different we will have
different ideas about what is best okay
so that might be a commercial thing it
might be our you know I don't want you
to send too much traffic through me
because it's going to cost me money to
look that's right right and basically
the idea is that when you're do
shortest path routing you want you know
you want everybody to be connected with
everybody and along the shortest path
and in the internet you want you don't
want traffic to be crossing your network
unless somebody's paying you for that
either the source of the traffic or the
destination or son or a combination
right somehow and so in other words the
the protocol is more about limiting the
connectivity rather than you know being
generous about it and giving it to
everyone it's kind of let's restrict
this connectivity to those that are
paying for it somehow that's basically
the idea but what I want what I want to
think about is well how does this fit
into our notion of finding paths in a
graph because in the undergraduate
computer science one of the things we
teach in algorithms courses is you know
a lot of shortest path algorithms so we
we define a graph let's say that is
nodes and arcs and you have a weight on
these arcs and then you try to find the
best paths between every pair of arcs
let's say and we typically teach this
and we teach lots of algorithms for
doing this like Dijkstra's algorithm
bellman-ford Warhols algorithm so can we
abstract away from the complexities of
BGP and think about it in those terms
the thing is it's it doesn't quite fit
in our models very well and and and I'll
try to explain informally why not well
what doesn't fit the BGP or what does it
fit okay so we normally think about
shortest paths in terms of numeric
values okay so and we typically add
those values as we go along a path right
so maybe maybe each arc has a weight one
and we essentially count the number of
hops that we're going through a path and
then we would prefer let's say a shorter
path one with fewer hops than a longer
one so we're what we're using there are
two operations plus and maybe an
operation let's call it min
okay so we have these operations min and
plus so min for minimum yeah plus for
adding up those hops yeah right and so
what people notice that about 40 years
ago is that a lot of these algorithms
that we have for shortest paths
Dijkstra's algorithm bellman-ford can be
generalized to a large class of
algebraic structures called semi rings
I'm gonna show you what is a really
stupid question I'm sure okay semi ring
I'm not familiar with a semi ring okay
so a semi ring is a algebraic structure
that looks like a ring so what is a ring
a ring is something like the real
numbers so we have domain the real
numbers and we have a plus and a times
they are plus and times the the standard
operations and a linear algebra is built
on rings
where actually we take matrices we
multiply matrices we solve matrix
equations things like that that's all
linear algebra well it turns out that
semi rings and routing is also it's kind
it's kind of like a generalization of
that where we we weaken the properties
that the the plus and the times have to
have right so for example a ring that
plus has inverses we have negative
numbers so there's always a for every a
there's a not there's a negative a that
when you add them together you get zero
okay and the semi ring is like a ring
except it doesn't have that inverse
property you don't necessarily have
inverses what people did back in the 60s
and 70s is they looked at algorithms
like Dijkstra's algorithm like
bellman-ford and then they said wait a
minute let's work backwards let's look
at these we see min and Plus in the
algorithms but let's replace them by
abstract operators and let's see what
algebraic properties we need to make
this algorithm work still suppose we
want to pick paths that have the highest
capacity okay so we might instead of
using plus we might go along a path
using min the weight of a path will be
the minimum
capacity link and then instead of using
min to compare paths we might want to
use max so that would give us the
highest capacity path okay so people
noticed oh wait a minute you know this
min plus and this max min they have
certain algebraic properties that are
true and we can we can take Dijkstra's
algorithm and we can replace the plus
with min and replace the min with Max
and now we have an algorithm that does
it works perfectly fine now it now it
finds the highest capacity paths in the
graph and then we can build other things
for example suppose I wanted to find
paths that were shortest but if I had
two paths that were equally short maybe
I want to break ties with capacity ok so
then now I could have a path with two
metrics you know distance capacity right
and then I could essentially you know a
use shortest paths on that first
component and then break ties with
capacity okay that to that that that
turns out you can make a semi ring out
of this and then guess what you can use
Dijkstra's algorithm bellman-ford to
compute with these as well if you
compare things you know first distance
then capacity kind of its kind of a
lexicographic comparison there you can
build a semi ring out of that and then
and so these these algorithms are really
generic you can just plug in you can
plug in you know just an unbounded
number of different algebraic structures
to get what you want and use the same
algorithms bellman-ford or Dijkstra etc
so this might seem like oh now we have
this open-ended world
maybe we can model something like BGP in
this world turns out we can't okay and
let me give you an example of that's
easy easier to understand than BGP okay
I told you we could do we could we could
look at distance first then break ties
with bandwidth suppose we or capacity
let's suppose we did it the other way
around I want the highest capacity pads
and if I have to cope at a best pass
with high capacity I want to break ties
then on the distance so I first look at
the at the capacity component then I
break ties on distance that's not a semi
ring anymore why is that oh it's not
obvious that you know if you use some of
these generic best path algorithms it's
something's going to break maybe why is
that not obvious but it turns out that
one of the rules of that needs to be
followed by a semi ring is something
called just distributivity this is an
algebraic property what it really means
is that you know it doesn't really
matter if I make a decision about the
best path seeing all my past or you my
neighbor you make the decisions and you
tell me what your best path is it kind
of doesn't really matter because we'll
come to the site we'll come to the same
conclusion right so that's what
distributivity is all about and this
this thing I told you about
you know shortest path then capacity
that has that property still but when I
turn it around when I do capacity first
and then shortest paths it breaks that
property okay and let me just give you
an example of why suppose I have a
neighbor that sees two paths one's very
high bandwidth but also a very long path
right and it sees another one with very
low bandwidth or capacity but it has a
short path and then I am talking to my
neighbor over a very low capacity link
so my neighbor picks that high capacity
long path but I see two paths and I say
wait a minute this is kind of like a
bottleneck link is sort of wipes out the
the capacity you know it's the the
capacity of both paths is now the
capacity of this really lousy link as
far as I'm concerned both of those paths
that my neighbor is giving me have the
capacity because I have this bottleneck
link with very low capacity so I'm going
to break ties on the length and I'm
going to break ties I'm going to want
that shortest path but my neighbor
picked the longer path because it had a
higher capacity but I don't see that you
see so we're going to be disagreeing
about this okay so a similar thing
happens in the internet for example if
I'm a paying customer of a route of a
path let's say I'm paying upstream I'm
paying for this route but my neighbor is
a service provider one of those paths
it's not paying for because it's a it's
their customer another path it's paying
for you know it's up it has an upstream
provider so that that that path could be
my neighbor would like the longer path
because it's a from a paying customer
from an economic point of view they like
that longer path but I I see the two
routes as well they're both provider
paths they're both equally bad in that
sense so I'll pick the shorter one so we
don't agree there's one thing I should
say about internet routing that I was
I've been sort of taking for granted
without really making it explicit and
that is 99% of internet routing
protocols only they they they're their
traffic insensitive okay that is they're
perfectly willing to route all the
traffic along the most congested link in
the internet okay in other words they
don't route around congestion so this is
the traffic difference between right
yeah and so telco protocols routed
around things like congestion but
Internet protocols have tradition there
are a few exceptions but generally
protocols like BGP OSPF is is and and
rip do not route around congestion
that's considered sort of a network
that's at done that network management
timescales so a network manager will see
oh we have congestion over there let's
adjust the link weights so that the
traffic will be
more or divergent the protocol doesn't
do that the protocol just blindly
follows those link weights those
statically configured link weights it's
not sensitive to traffic characteristics
and this is because in the Internet
those characteristics tend to change a
lot and oscillate a lot and they tend to
often oscillate in a at a faster rate
than the control plane can keep up with
and so you you when you try to adapt
dynamically to congestion you tend to
introduce a lot of instability in the
routing plane and so these things are
you know completely insensitive to to
traffic conditions like congestion it's
up to the network managers to set those
statically configured link weights to
avoid congestion so this is more like
the road size they tell you where those
things go yes they don't change yes I
think internet forwarding is a lot like
those signs that just point you in that
direction you know Paris is in that
direction go if you're heading towards
Paris go that way a complicated thing of
course is that when we have now these
regions that are divided up into
autonomous regions that have very
different goals but they're forced to
interact
all right BT is forced to exchange
routes with AT&T because they're selling
the service of global Internet
connectivity so they're forced to
interact with their competitors they
they'd like to control the entire
internet I'm sure but they can't
there's a balance you want to allow each
network to tailor its let's call them
routing policies or routing policies
sorry I've been in the UK for 12 years
so I'm saying routing now